click bait is everywhere and it's
ruining online spaces people are getting
duped by misleading titles and subject
lines into clicking on absolute garbage
and the people using these tactics are
manipulative shills just trying to farm
clicks and add dollars it's an epidemic
and it needs to stop so that's the video
I think a lot of people would want me to
make on this topic but it's not the
video that I want to make and
I want to help you understand why I'm
Drex and I make videos about flow arts
and POI spinning I like sharing the love
of these Arts to benefit your body and
brain but I also on occasion like to
Branch out into adjacent topics I am
after all a content creator in addition
to those other things and I do like
talking about that part of my job too
and in this video I want to talk about
why click bait is everywhere now but
also why it kind of has to be and what
it says about us that this has happened
but before we dive in I want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and a special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel Johnny Howard
Lane machinski and Becca becklinen thank
you all so very much for your support
from my work and my mission so a few
days ago I got an email from a guy who
was very angrily unsubscribing to my
email list his grievance was that my
email titles had gotten too clickbaity
and you know he's not wrong I have been
making changes to the subject lines of
my emails but I personally think that
it's for a good reason why have I been
making those changes and why have they
put him and I at loggerheads I actually
think those are really important
questions to ask and in so doing there's
a lot to learn about the tension between
artist and audience in the social media
era as well as who we are versus who we
think we are but before we dive too
deeply into that I think it's important
that we Define what clickbait really is
because I'm going to be using the word a
lot in this video personally I think the
best framing I have seen of this concept
is the one that Derek Muller of
veritasium used on his video exploring
this very topic according to Derek
clickbait is content whose main purpose
is to attract attention and encourage
visitors to click on a link to a
particular web page
yes I know that he offered up multiple
definitions in that video but this is
the one that I'm going with for
simplicity's sake now it has to be said
that I have very deliberately been
changing the style of my email subject
lines and video titles recently why is
that my channel enjoyed an unprecedented
surge in popularity early in the
pandemic that lasted for the better part
of a year and then slowly faded I had
centered the channel around tutorials
with the occasional Vlog review or video
essay on a variety of topics but the
tutorials were by far the most popular
option my channel had to offer just a
few years before I'd gotten really
interested in keyword targeting and had
gotten really good at ranking on YouTube
and Google searches associated with POI
tutorials and tricks I'd found several
formats that really tended to draw a lot
of eyeballs including list videos of my
top five favorite POI tricks of
different categories and my what comes
next series but as frequently happens on
online platforms the algorithms started
to shift and keywords became less and
less of a consideration on the
performance and some videos and it
should be said creatively I was looking
for new challenges and new topics to
cover too so not only did I start
exploring other formats for videos I
also started exploring other ways to get
people to watch if keywords in search
were no longer a reliable way to reach
people then I had to find other ways to
continue to reach an audience at Point
all the big heads in content creation
are saying that it's really coming down
to thumbnails and titles so I started
investing more time there I started
asking myself whenever I watched
somebody else's video why was I clicking
on it and I'd use the answers I'd arrive
at to guide my approach to my own
content sometimes it worked other times
it didn't but this project extended to
my email list too where before my
subject lines were pretty dry but
accurate descriptions of what was to be
found in the full email I started trying
out different subject lines that would
connect with that content but would
arouse what I keep seeing referred to as
the Curiosity Gap the Curiosity Gap
occurs when we see a teaser for
something say a phrase image or snippet
of video and we just have to find out
more about it it gives us just enough to
want to know more without giving us the
satisfaction of knowing exactly what
we're signing up for so back to that
mailing list subscriber here because
within his rage quitting there's a
really important piece of this puzzle to
understand
he has received over 40 emails from me
during his time on my list but the only
four he's ever opened were the most
recent ones that I sent and yes that's
right these were the ones with the
clickbaity subject lines in other words
Bruce isn't mad that I'm sending
clickbait subject lines
he's mad that they work he's mad that
I'm actually getting him to open up
those emails that I pay MailChimp every
month for the ability to send him and I
get it believe me I do because I get
frustrated with clickbait too most often
I get frustrated when I see a title or
subject line that seems to promise one
thing that builds my anticipation and
then gives me something completely
different once I finally click on it
there are absolutely ways in which click
bait can be really deceitful but here's
the problem the alternative is that I
just keep wasting money sending this guy
and others like him emails that they're
never going to open up and I know I know
I'm totally framing this as a binary and
it is not I will absolutely confess that
I strongly dislike clickbait and because
of that my own attempts to write similar
titles and subject lines are still
pretty crude I'm still figuring out the
art to this and I appreciate those of
you who are being patient with me as I
do so I also think there's something to
unpack from my own dislike of clickbait
to understand both why I'm so bad at it
as well as white people like that
subscriber are upset that I'm learning
how to do it
for the record he's not the only person
who has complained about my attempts to
learn how to use this concept but that's
not going to stop me from continuing to
learn so like most people I like to
think of myself as a pretty smart guy a
2018 paper found that 65 percent of
American adults believe that they are of
above average intelligence
on most days I like to think that I am
too we like thinking of ourselves as
smart and one of those things we
associate with being smart is the
capacity to verify information without
bias and not to be easily manipulated
there's no shortage of people who
believe that they are too smart to be
misled and yet there's a book that I
really love to quote from time to time
called Thinking Fast and Slow by Daniel
Kahneman that I legitimately think might
be one of the most fascinating books
I've ever read in my life and one of my
favorite parts of it is how it pokes
holes in our conception of how smart
people should be able to make smart
decisions one such example is a very
famous problem let's say you go down to
the corner store and pick up a toy
baseball and a toy baseball bat in total
you spent a dollar and 10 cents on both
and you spent a dollar more on the bat
than you did on the baseball
how much did you spend on each one now I
have given this problem to dozens of
friends physicists lawyers
mathematicians teachers and it's wild
because in presenting the problem I can
see them looking for the trick in it
they arrive almost instantly at what
seems like a very clear answer and ask
themselves that can't be it right but
still being drawn towards that very
answer even if they're skeptical of it
if you guessed that the bat cost a
dollar and the ball cost 10 cents then
congratulations you gave the same answer
as 80 percent of the people who answer
this same question for the first time
including myself
and we are all wrong the difference in
cost between a dollar and 10 cents is 90
cents not a dollar but because we grasp
onto what seemed like Crystal Clear
markers in the formulation of the
problem our brains refuse to let go of
these two numbers unless under great
duress the answer is actually that the
bat cost a dollar and five cents and the
ball cost five cents and it seems
obnoxiously obvious in retrospect right
the difference between people who opt
for the first answer versus the second
answer though isn't a question of
intelligence it's a question of what
Kahneman refers to as System One versus
system two thinking wherein system one
is fast intuitive and satisfying system
two is slow difficult to parse and
frequently unpleasant to engage in
precisely because it requires us to
engage more of our brain's resources in
utilizing it okay so why am I talking
about a behavioral psychology problem in
a video about click bait well it's
because we as human beings are prone to
impulse and finding quick answers to
questions and many of us who pride
ourselves on being smart hate being
reminded that we still do this because
really people wouldn't use click bait if
it didn't work if those titles didn't
Engage The Curiosity Gap if it were not
easier to click on them then it would be
to engage in system 2 Thinking every
time I click on something that engages
that Curiosity Gap I know that I
certainly feel angry and frustrated when
the resulting content seems to fall
maddeningly short of the expectations
that the title generated for me and it
becomes a humbling reminder that I too
can easily be misled my frustration and
anger is not at the author of The Click
bait it's that myself for realizing that
I was gullible enough to fall for it and
it also becomes a problem for me
learning how to do it myself because I
have spent so much time resenting
clickbait that I avoided learning from
it there is an art to finding a balance
between creating a title that is so
misleading that it will disappoint
everyone versus coming up with one that
does arouse the Curiosity Gap and also
delivers real satisfaction for the
viewer if they click on it and I have to
say one of the weirdest elements of
getting pushback on this is that when
people complain about clickbait titles
whether they realize it or not they're
basically saying hey I'm cool with you
creating content just so long as you
don't actually try to get anybody to
watch it now don't get me wrong there's
a lot of Click bait out there that does
not deliver on one's expectations but
the problem is that we are now at a
point in the maturation of online
content where we can't really work
without it after all which title would
you be more likely to click on this POI
trick broke me or behind the back waist
wrap combo the former engages your
curiosity it feels relatable and you
wonder what could possibly have been
that hard for me the latter tells you
exactly what it is and because of that
you're likely to leave it for when
you're in the specific mood to watch it
if you even remember to watch it at all
click bait exists because in an
information economy built on one of of
our most scarce resources that is human
attention the ability to appeal to
people was always going to be a race to
the bottom we basically have two
extremes of how we engage with content
right now it's either stuff that arouses
our curiosity Gap to Crave answers so
much that we can't help ourselves to
them or stuff that is so familiar
unchallenging and predictable that it's
comforting to engage with the latter
really only works for Star Wars and MCU
movies the former is the realm of
YouTube Instagram and Tech talk we as
content creators have to play this game
or we become irrelevant and I really
want to be clear here I'm actually okay
with this the human brain always lags
behind the technology that surrounds it
and we have to play catch-up for how it
engages with said technology
I'm not bemoaning the fact that in order
to stay relevant I have to experiment
with click bait though I am a little
frustrated by how long it's taking to
learn the techniques of it but once upon
a time keyword targeting was really hard
for me too and I got a lot better at it
over the years this too I show work to
improve on thanks to all of you for
being patient with me while I do did you
get anything out of this video please
leave a comment like subscribe and share
to keep the conversation going and to
help other people find this video this
video would not be possible if it were
not for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions Vlogs reviews Combos and
more I'm on a mission to try and bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to The Wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link down in the description
or the card that just popped up if you
are watching on YouTube there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out more of my
videos on content creation I'm going to
leave a link to a playlist of videos on
that topic down in the description as
well as up on screen if you are watching
on YouTube the YouTube algorithm also
thinks that you'll like this top video
based upon your viewing history too so
maybe give that a shot as well thanks so
much for watching and make sure to get
outside and flow today I'll see you the
brand new video on Wednesday
peace